All right.
It is 9:20. So, let's get started.
Good morning.
Uh for those of you who are taking the
class at UCSC, uh
congratulations. You just finished uh
20% of the course.
Only 80% left to go.
So,
uh last time we started to talk about
causal broadcast, and uh we started to
sketch out uh an implementation of
causal broadcast using vector clocks.
And uh we didn't really write down the
rules in any kind of a formal way. So,
this time we're going to start out by
doing that.
So, let's come back to this topic of
causal broadcast.
And just to refresh our memory uh from
last time, uh
let's put up our picture again of
our classic causal anomaly.
So,
what we figured out last time is that
the the the issue here was that this
message here uh
was delivered before this message uh
being sent uh
by by Alice, even though this message
should be causally later.
Uh and we sketched out how we could use
vector clocks to present that prevent
that. Uh in particular, uh if every
process is keeping a vector clock,
and then these messages have vector
clocks uh attached to them when they're
sent. So for example, this first message
from Alice,
its vector clock is 100. So it's
incremented in Alice's position because
this send on Alice counts as an event.
The message arrives at Bob and Bob is
okay to deliver it because
it's only bigger than Bob's in one
position. It's bigger than Bob's in the
position of the sender. So Bob is okay
to deliver that message.
Uh
when this message gets sent, the vector
clock attached to it
is 110.
Because Bob now knows about the one
event from Alice and he's now
incrementing
one for this event on himself. Again,
we're only counting message sends as
events.
So receives don't count as events in
this particular algorithm.
Uh
this message arrives here,
but then it gets queued.
Because
a message with a vector clock of 110 at
this point on Carol is too big to
deliver.
So this message gets queued. This other
message arrives with its vector clock of
100 and that one can be delivered and at
that point this message
can come out of the queue
and be delivered.
This one over here could be delivered
right away.
So that's one example, but what are the
rules in general for doing this? So
let's start to write that down.
Okay, so causal broadcast.
So first rule.
If a message
sent by process one
is delivered
at process two
increment
process two's
local clock
in the process one position.
So maybe we should have done that here
just to make it a little bit more
explicit. So here
uh this message is being delivered at
Bob uh
because the message was coming from
Alice
and it's being delivered at Bob, we
could we should increment Bob's local
clock in the Alice position. So that
should change to one there.
Here nothing changes according to that
rule because this message just gets
queued. Um here this one Alice this
would have already changed to one and
then this would change to one and then
finally here uh
uh we can update Alice's clock when this
message uh
uh gets delivered and then when this one
gets delivered as well.
So that's the first rule.
Then we say
if a message
is sent by a process
first
increment its own position
and its local clock
and include the local clock along with
the message.
So, these vector clocks are being
attached to these messages as metadata
that comes along with them.
All right, last one, the tricky one.
This is the property that tells you when
it is that you're allowed to deliver a
message.
So, we say
a message sent
by a process P1
is only delivered
at P2
if
and we're going to say this message sent
uh
by P1 has a timestamp which a vector
clock
uh so, if
for the message's timestamp
T
and this is a logical timestamp. So,
this is not uh like a time of day
timestamp, it's a vector clock.
Um
this condition has to be true.
I'm kind of running out of room, so I'm
actually going to move to another sheet
here.
We say that
the timestamp, and this again is
the vector clock attached to P1, or
excuse me, the vector clock attached to
the message coming from P1.
So, in the P1 position on that vector
clock
it has to be the case that
the vector clock
on the process that we're sending to
that one has to be one less.
So, the timestamp of P1
in the position of the process that
we're sending from
has to be one bigger than whatever that
position was in the vector clock on the
receiving process. So, that has to be
true.
And
it also has to be the case that
the timestamp for every other position
let's call it K
has to be less than or equal to
that position in in the the vector clock
on the receiving process.
For all K other than the the K the of
the process that's sending the message.
So,
I'm going to write down uh condition
three up here again. Um so, these are
the rules uh
rule for
when
you can deliver
a message
sent
uh
from
P1
at P2
under causal broadcast.
So, what do these two conditions mean?
So, the the first one up here
uh means that the time stamp on the
message makes it the next expected
message from P1.
VC here is is whatever
the process two's local clock says.
So, this condition says that, for
example, if the message comes from Alice
and it has a time stamp of 100
and Bob's local clock is 000 then that's
okay because
in that position in Alice's position it
was one higher.
Then there's the other condition here.
Which says that for every other position
in the in the vector clock other than
the senders position.
The timestamp
is at most as big as the local clock.
In other words it says that there are no
messages missing from any other
processes out there.
So that's what these two conditions
ensure.
The general idea here is to make sure
that the sender
doesn't have more information than the
receiver about the state of all of the
other processes.
So
in particular we want to rule out this
kind of situation.
Where
we want where where this message
here
would cause confusion on Carol because
Carol knows about some state
because or because Bob knows about some
state that Carol doesn't know about yet.
So
this rule
is what makes it possible for us to
queue this message here rather than
delivering it immediately. Here's the
that uh
rule again.
Questions about this?
So there's a question in chat which says
with these rules wouldn't Bob's clock be
200 after delivering the first message
from Alice. Well, let's look at it.
So,
after delivering the first message from
Alice. So, like right here,
I'm not sure why it would be.
Um so, Alice at this point when she
sends this message uh
uh it has a timestamp of 100. I think
what you're thinking of is that uh I
think you're still thinking of the of
the notion of counting receives as
events.
So, yeah. So, keep in mind that uh with
this particular algorithm, we don't
count receiving of messages as events.
With the vector clock algorithm that I
showed before, uh when we were just
assigning vector clocks to events and uh
and we were using that to determine uh
which events happened before other
events and which events were
independent, uh everything counted as an
event then. Receives counted, sends
counted, internal events counted. Uh but
with this, uh
we only count sends as events.
So, there's another question on in chat.
Uh so, when the local clock is sent by a
process, uh
uh we don't absorb the local clock into
the new process. Um
uh
Or or or we don't absorb the the sent
clock into the new process. No, we
absolutely do. Um so, uh
So, when
uh
when this message from
uh from Alice
uh arrives here at Bob, right? Bob's
clock here increments here in the Alice
position because that message came from
Alice uh
uh
with a one in that position.
So, yeah. We're still definitely uh
using the clocks that are sent along.
Otherwise, we wouldn't need to send the
clock as metadata.
Uh but we still we still need to use
that information.
So, we say
if a message sent by process one is
delivered at process two, that's when we
increment processes process two's local
clock.
So, this is where the increment occurs.
It So, it happens at delivery time.
So, this is the complete algorithm. I've
written down everything here.
Uh there's not there's there's not some
uh
um implicit information about taking the
maximum of vector clocks. This is This
is it. So, when you it So, the question
in chat is uh confusion about when to do
step one. Maybe you're assuming that
there is some uh
um some taking the max of vector clocks
that happens externally to this
algorithm. But this is actually it.
So, this
uh
uh kind of uh um I I forget the word I'm
looking for here, but this uh
um
subsumes. That's the word I want. This
subsumes what we were doing before with
taking the maximum of vector clocks, if
that makes sense.
Yes. So, that's why So, the question in
chat now is are all messages always sent
to all processes? Yeah, so that's why
it's causal broadcast.
So, this would not work
if we weren't sending all messages to
all processes.
So, that's a great question. So, I think
somebody asked asked this actually last
time uh and uh so the question last time
was something like, "Oh, well, what if
um well, if what if Alice only sent her
message to Bob and then Bob sent his
message to Alice and Carol?" Um then
would this message be delayed? So, there
was a question like that and I think I I
I kind of made light of the question
last time and said something about how
that would make Bob a jerk, uh which it
would, but also that wouldn't make sense
under this algorithm because in this
algorithm, we're assuming that all
messages are broadcast messages. So, a
message a message that just went from
Alice to Bob,
this technique for ensuring uh causal
message delivery wouldn't work then
because this is only for when all
messages are broadcast messages. Now, it
turns out that a lot of the time, that's
what you want. Uh so, this is a very uh
useful algorithm.
Uh
if you wanted to ensure that all
messages uh were delivered if you were
if you wanted to ensure causal delivery
in a setting where not all messages were
broadcast messages, um that's something
uh
that's something that you can think
about on your own. You'd have to do
something a little bit more
sophisticated then.
So, I I I think there's a little bit of
confusion in chat uh about uh about this
uh versus what I showed earlier. So,
these are both algorithms that use
vector clocks.
Uh
and before, what we did was when you
received a a a before we were we were we
were talking about using vector clocks
to assign or we were talking about
assigning vector clocks to events,
events that had already happened. So, we
were saying, "Looking at a a collection
of events that have already occurred,
let's assign vector clocks to those
events so that we can try to understand
what happened before what." Uh this is a
little different because we're talking
about as the events are occurring, we're
talking about using vector clocks to
decide whether or not to deliver
messages as they're happening. So, these
are the it's the same concept in either
case, but they're different uses of
vector clocks.
Uh, yeah. So, another question is um
after we've completed all the sends, are
all the vector clocks for each process
uh
uh 110.
Uh, yeah, that's right. So, this one
here for Bob should have been 110.
Or rather, not after we've completed all
all the all the sends, but after we've
completed all the delivers.
So, let's do another example.
I'm a little bit bored of this one.
So, let's say again we have Alice, Bob,
and Carol.
Okay. So, say Alice sends a message here
and she says,
"I lost my wallet."
And let's say she sends that to Bob and
Carol.
The vector clock attached to this
message is 100.
Is this message okay to deliver when it
gets to Bob?
Sure.
So, it gets delivered at Bob.
It's also okay to deliver it Carol.
Alice sends another message.
Say she finds her wallet.
To Bob.
Is this one okay to deliver?
Yeah, you bet.
So, this one gets delivered, too.
Bob sends a response.
Glad to hear it.
Maybe you see where this is going.
Oh, yeah, this should have been
broadcast. It is broadcast, but we're
going to say that this one takes a
little bit longer.
So, maybe now you really see where this
is going.
So, Bob says, "Glad to hear it."
Sends that to Alice.
I I suppose I should write the vector
clock here, too. So, this was 200.
What's the vector clock attached to this
glad to hear it message?
Yeah, that's right. That one should be
210.
It gets here.
Is it okay to deliver that message at
Alice?
Sure.
Deliver that one.
But if it also comes over here to Carol,
is that one okay to deliver?
Nope.
Thankfully not, right? Cuz Carol would
probably be pretty unhappy if if Bob's
response to Alice with losing her wallet
was glad to hear it.
So, that one gets queued.
And then finally this one arrives.
So, this message here
had 100. So, Carol's local clock has now
been incremented to 100. When the next
message arrives from Alice with the
clock of 200, that one's okay to
deliver, too.
So, that one can get delivered.
And then finally, so this 200
corresponds to to both this and this
here.
And then finally, this one down here
that got queued
is okay to deliver now.
So, here again
uh the causal broadcast algorithm
prevented uh
uh some horrible faux pas from taking
place. So, Carol's or Carol does not see
this glad to hear it message until she
sees Alice's message saying that she
found her wallet.
Ah.
So, there's a question in chat. Uh don't
we have a problem when two processes
send at the same time and messages pass
each other? Um so, this is a great
question. Yeah, so this is actually
anticipates the next thing that I want
to talk about. So,
the next question is
does this vector clock stuff establish a
total order on messages?
Remember what our total order anomaly
looked like.
So, what if we tried to prevent this
total order anomaly using vector clocks?
What would happen?
Well,
okay, so we got client one here, right?
Sending a message.
So, what would the vector clock on that
message be? 1 0 0 0, right?
Message arrives at replica one, it's
okay to deliver.
Client two is sending a message here, so
the vector clock on this one would be
like 0 0 0 1.
Message arrives at replica two.
The if these
uh uh uh
processes all start out with 0 0 0 0 as
their vector clocks, then this one's
okay to deliver, right? Because it's
only one bigger than replica two's uh
local clock in the sender's position, so
we go ahead and deliver it.
This one arrives here.
So, now at this point uh replica one's
local clock looks like this.
The message from C2 arrives.
Uh replica one's clock is 1000.
The message from C2 is 0001.
Is that okay to deliver according to the
rules that we had before?
So here's the rules.
So we said
the timestamp on the message uh
from the the process that's delivering
it uh has to make it the next expec-
expected message. So it has to be one
bigger uh in the in the position that it
So So this is the vector clock. This T
here is the vector clock on the incoming
message that's attached as metadata to
the message.
So this has to say uh it's it's one
bigger than whatever the local clock on
the process receiving the message thinks
uh
for that particular uh for for that
sending processes position.
But then here
we say
the timestamp
for every other for on on the on the
vector clock attached to the message it
has to be less than or equal to
uh the vector clock on the receiving
process
uh for every position.
So is that true here? Well, yeah, it is.
So this vector clock attached to the
message 0001,
it's one less than this clock up here,
but that's okay
uh because this is less than or equal
here.
So, that's actually fine. The point of
this rule is to to rule out uh messages
that are coming from the future.
But, this message isn't coming from the
future.
Uh, replica one receives the message
with this timestamp of 0001.
The only place where it's bigger is in
the sender's position, and it's only
bigger there by one.
So, according to the causal broadcast
algorithm, this is actually perfectly
fine to deliver right here.
Likewise, here on replica two, so right
now replica two's clock is 000
or it's yeah, 0001.
This message comes in. It has a
timestamp of 1000.
It's one bigger than the current clock
in the sender's position, that first
position there.
It's less than the sender uh the excuse
me, it's less than the receiver's clock
in this last position, but that's okay
according to causal broadcast. So, this
one's actually okay to deliver, too.
So, these messages here, the ones that
could potentially
uh
cause these replicas to disagree
are actually fine to deliver under the
causal broadcast algorithm.
So,
causal delivery
doesn't rule out
total order anomalies.
And we kind of saw that hinted at
before, didn't we? Because when we when
we sketched out a a hierarchy of
delivery guarantees, we saw that total
order was on its own branch, right? We
saw that it wasn't uh
it wasn't a more restrictive delivery
guarantee
than causal delivery. And so nor was it
nor was causal delivery more restrictive
than it. So there are some things that
are total order anomalies
that ensuring causal delivery still
wouldn't rule out. And there are things
that are causal anomalies that
ensuring total order doesn't doesn't
rule out. So
So no.
We can see that these messages here are
not in violation of the causal delivery
protocol that we wrote down.
So if we wanted to enforce total order
if we wanted to rule out anomalies like
this one, we would need something more
than vector clocks.
Or at least if we wanted to keep causal
order and also have total order, we
would need something more than this
particular causal
causal broadcast algorithm that we just
wrote down.
In general, total order is really
annoying to have to enforce. So I
suggest not enforcing it unless you
really have to.
Questions about this?
All right.
So
I want to pause and do a quiz question.
But I also want to talk about the
answers to the quiz questions from
before.
So here were our quiz questions from
last week.
So,
uh
on Monday of last week, uh
we asked about uh
if A happens before B, then what can you
say about the Lamport clocks of A and B?
So,
this is what you do know,
uh
uh from from Lamport clocks, right? If A
happens before B, then we know that the
Lamport clock of A uh is less than
Lamport clock of B. We don't have the
other direction with Lamport clocks. Uh
we only have this direction of that
implication. So, in particular, if the
Lamport clock of A is less than the
Lamport clock of B, you don't know that
A happened before B. It could be the
case that A and B are concurrent, or it
could be that B happened before A.
That was from Monday.
On Wednesday, we asked about vector
clocks, uh pointwise maximum. Uh so,
this is pretty straightforward. You just
take these two vector clocks, and uh you
take the max in each position. So, if
the clocks are 0 2 1 0 and 0 1 0 3, then
the pointwise maximum in this case is
going to be 0 2 1 3.
And then,
Friday, we said,
"Complete the definition of the FIFO
delivery process." We said, "If a
process sends a message M2 after message
M1," and the answer here is
if a process sends M2 after M1, then any
process that's delivering both of those
messages, and we're talking about the
same receiving process, any process that
delivers both of them messages has to
has to deliver M1 first. That's FIFO
delivery.
So, those were our quiz questions for
last time.
Uh and now, let's do today's quiz
question.
It's all posted in chat.
Yeah, I'll fix it.
Okay, it should be fixed now.
All right, we'll wait like one more
minute.
Okay, let's call it good.
Okay.
Back to
the lecture.
So,
um
So, we've just been talking about about
causal broadcast, right? Uh and I want
to I want to say something
about uh
ways
that
potential causality
And by potential causality, I mean the
happens-before relation
is used
in distributed systems.
Um so, we just talked about two of them,
right? Uh
We talked about how um
how we can use vector clocks to um
to a to
to assign we can assign vector clocks to
events to determine the ordering of
events
after the fact.
For debugging.
And then we can also use vector clocks
uh or this notion of happens before
live while the while a an algorithm is
running uh to do things like causal
broadcast um
So I'll just say causal ordering
of events
as they're happening.
So sometimes you'll you'll hear people
talk about causal consistency. Uh it's
not quite a synonym with causal
broadcast, but they're related. Um, so
all these things provide ordering
guarantees that prevent causal
anomalies.
Um, what's something else that you can
do with causality?
Um, so
one thing that we haven't talked about
yet
This is kind of related to the first
point uh is what's called consistent
global snapshots.
So this is a way of getting a picture of
the global state of the of a distributed
system. And it's it's not trivial to do
because
each of these processes in a distributed
system has its own state, right? And its
own knowledge about other processes
states.
So, there are some ways to try to take a
go a global snapshot that makes sense
and some ways that really don't make
sense.
But
as a general rule, it may not surprise
you to learn that
it A if A happens before B
and B
is in the snapshot
then A should be, too.
So, this notion of consistent global
snapshots is another important use of
the happens before relation or another
important use of potential causality.
Uh and that's what we're going to talk
about next.
So
before we get into the details of of
this uh snapshot algorithm, let me just
kind of talk at a high level
uh about
what it means to try to take a global
snapshot of a distributed system. So
something that we've talked about a
little bit so far uh is that in a
distributed system, there's not really
such a thing
as an observable global state, right?
So, individual processes have states
and we said that the state of a process,
right, amounts to
all of the events that have taken place
on it, right? So, if you have a bunch of
events
maybe these ones are internal events and
then maybe there's also some messages
being received,
maybe there's some messages being sent
and so on.
So, we say that a state of a process
amounts to all the events that have
happened on it up until until some
particular point.
Uh and we could also say that whatever
it's storing in its local memory could
be part of that state. But that could
also be expressed as internal events.
Uh in any case
I could sort of
lasso up all the events that have
occurred on a process
and then say ta-da
there's its state.
But in general uh we have several
processes, right? And we want to be able
to talk about the state
of the entire system.
So if we had some sort of globally
synchronized time of day clock we could
say
okay, everybody take a snapshot of
yourself at 9:20 a.m.
Uh but we can't do that because my 9:20
a.m. isn't necessarily the same as your
one your 9:20 a.m. So this could lead to
problems.
Um
so just to give you an example of that
um for instance uh what if let's say
let's say one process's clock let's say
P1's clock
uh is set a little bit earlier than
process two's clock.
Um then process one might take a
snapshot at what it thinks is 9:20 a.m.
And then it might send a message to
process two. So let's say that some
events have happened on process two.
And let's say that right here
is what process one thinks is 9:20 a.m.
So it takes its snapshot there. Let's
say it send it sends a message right
here.
And let's say that this
is what process two thinks is 9:20 a.m.
So if process two's clock ticks over to
9:20 a.m. after receiving that message
and maybe some other events happened on
process two before this.
Then the snapshot
on process one would look like that, but
the snapshot on process two
would look like this.
So then we would have a snapshot that
didn't make sense, right? Because we
would have this event here that was
supposed to happen before this event
according to the happens before relation
because it was uh the send that goes
with this receive, um but it's not in
the snapshot.
So we have this event that's in the
snapshot that came from nowhere
uh because we tried to use
time of day clocks.
So this approach of telling everybody,
"Okay, take a snapshot of yourself at a
particular time."
uh this is prone to errors because not
everybody's clock can be perfectly
synchronized. Uh P2's piece of the
snapshot here says that it got a message
before 9:20 and P1 says it never
happened.
So clearly time of day clocks are not
going to be good enough for us uh in
taking snapshots. So what we need is
some sort of algorithm that will allow
us to take a global snapshot that
actually makes sense.
Um so we're going to start to talk about
a a classic algorithm for doing that.
Uh and it's called the Chandy-Lamport
algorithm.
As so often in distributed systems uh
it's named after
uh
Leslie Lamport.
Uh and also somebody else uh
uh Mani Chandy, another famous
distributed systems person. So
the story behind this is that so
supposedly um they were hanging out over
dinner one night and talking about how
to compute distributed global snapshots.
And uh according to to Lamport's version
of the story, they'd had a little too
much wine and they couldn't figure out
how to solve the problem right then.
Um so supposedly, according to Lamport,
he came up with the solution in the
shower the next morning. And uh he went
to Chandy's office and Chandy was
waiting for him there with the same
solution.
Uh so they ended up co-authoring this
paper about it.
Um so let's talk about how it works. Um
it's actually fairly straightforward, I
think. Um
so so first um
I'll try to write down what the
algorithm does, um and then we'll work
out an example together. Actually, I
don't know if we're really going to have
time to write down what the algorithm
does today. Might have to save it till
next time. Um so first I'm going to
establish some terminology, and then
we'll see how we do.
Um so
the new piece of terminology that we
need, that I kind of hinted at a little
bit before when we were talking about
FIFO, um is the notion of a channel.
So a channel
can be thought of as a connection from
one process to another.
Um so let's say if we have processes P1
and P2
that are sending and receiving messages.
Um there are actually two channels here.
Uh there's a channel from P1 to P2,
and there's a channel from P2 to P1.
So the convention in naming these
channels is the channel from P1 to P2 is
called C12.
And the channel from P2 to P1 is called
C21.
So, in general, channel CIJ is the
channel from process PI to process PJ.
Um so, in this picture, um
one message has been sent from process
one to process two. So, at this point,
um we're going to say this message has
already been sent, the one that uh
where the send is event A and the
receive is event B. And then there's
this other message here, um whose send
is event C here, and this message is
currently in flight uh from P2 to P1.
So,
we say that this message
uh from P2 to P1 is currently in the
channel C21.
So, in this particular picture, channel
C12 was empty um because there's no
messages currently in flight from P1 to
P2, and channel C21 has one message in
it, this message right here.
We're going to assume
that messages arrive in FIFO order.
So, that is there is no FIFO violations.
So, channels will act like FIFO queues.
So, this is enough to prevent FIFO
violations. As we've seen, preventing
FIFO violations is not enough to present
prevent violations of causality and it's
not enough to prevent total order
violations. But at least we have this.
So we're we're assuming that messages
only get sent in FIFO order.
Okay.
Um
So let's in the short time that we have
left, um let's try to do a really simple
example of uh
of running the Chandy-Lamport algorithm.
Uh
So one particular process kicks things
off.
Um and we call it the initiator process.
Um so
Say again that we just have P1 and P2
and we have message like this
and then one like this.
Let's say that P1 here is the initiator
process. Let's say that P1 decides to
start taking a snapshot and it takes
that snapshot right after message A is
sent.
So what it does is it records its state
right there.
We're going to call this S1.
After it records its state
it sends what's called a marker message.
Uh and it sends that marker message out
on all of its outgoing channels. In this
case it only has one outgoing channel
because there are only two processes in
this system. Uh
so it has its its outgoing channel to
P2.
Um so it sends what's called a marker
message.
And I'm going to draw this differently
to differentiate it from these ones up
here which are These are messages that
are actually part of the running
application. So this one is a marker.
It sends a marker message. Uh it has to
do that before it So, it does that I
really should have drawn it starting up
here.
Um it has to do that before it does
anything else
uh after snapshotting its own state.
And then, after it sends that marker
message, it starts recording the
messages that it receives on all of its
incoming channels. In this case, it only
has one incoming channel, the one from
P2.
Okay, so what happens when somebody
receives a marker message?
There are two cases. So,
when a process receives a marker
message,
uh
if it's the first marker that that
process has seen,
it records its state,
uh it marks the channel that it got the
marker message on as empty,
and it sends a marker out on all of it
its outgoing channels.
Um
if it's already seen a marker message
before,
then it's going to stop recording
on that channel,
and it's going to set that channel's
final state as all of the incoming
messages that arrived uh since recording
began. So, TLDR, if it's already seen a
marker message and it receives another
one, then it stops recording incoming
messages on that channel. That's a lot
of words, so let me try to um
uh summarize it in this picture a little
bit better.
Um so, in our example,
P2 records its state
right here when it receives this marker
message.
I'll call this one S2.
It doesn't have any other incoming
channels uh to record on, right? So, it
doesn't have to do that.
And what it does now is it sends a
marker message back to P1.
Um
and it marks its incoming channel as
empty.
What does P1 do when it gets the marker
message?
Um has it already seen a marker message?
We say that it has. It sent one in the
first place. So, that we say that counts
as seeing one. So, yes, it saw one. So,
what does it do? It stops recording on
its incoming channel that the marker
message came in on.
Did it record anything during that time
that it since it sent its marker
message? Let's say that it did. Let's
say that this message actually arrived
over here.
It got this message
whose send was C and whose uh receive
was D.
So, that actually has to be captured
somehow. Um so, that actually goes into
the recorded state.
So, now we have everything recorded. We
have the state of process one.
We have the state of process two.
Um and we got the state of the channels.
Um so, this snapshot is done.
Does this snapshot make sense?
Well, what would be a snapshot that
didn't make sense? So, it would be
really really weird, right, if the
snapshot had B but not A, right?
Um so, this would be Here Here's a
snapshot that wouldn't make sense.
So, if this were S2 and this were S1
over here. So, this would be a snapshot
that wouldn't make sense, right? Because
we have this A here and then we have
this B that's supposed to A is supposed
to happen before B, um but A wasn't
captured as part of the snapshot.
Or here's another one that wouldn't make
sense.
This one wouldn't make sense, either.
Because we've got C here,
but we don't have B which happened to be
for C. So, these would be weird
snapshots.
Um as it turns out, the the
Chandy-Lamport algorithm won't let you
take a snapshot like that.
What if it's something like this?
So, is this one a legal snapshot?
Yeah, this one's a perfectly good
snapshot. Um so, what happened in this
case is
process one snapshot at its own state.
Um it sent a marker message.
And
say the marker message uh responding
marker message uh from process two uh
came back uh
pretty quickly.
So
this message from C to D never gets uh
neither of these events ever gets
included in the snapshot. Um but it
turns out that that's fine in terms of
it being a legal snapshot.
And what happens is that
all of these individual snapshots of the
different processes get stitched
together by the Chandy-Lamport algorithm
into
uh into the global snapshot.
Uh or really I guess I shouldn't say
that doesn't that doesn't happen as part
of the Chandy-Lamport algorithm. The
algorithm is done running at the point
when every process has snapshotted its
own state and then you can imagine some
other process running later that goes
around and collect up all of the
individual snapshots of the individual
states and stitches them together uh
into a global snapshot.
So
I went through that really quickly uh
because we only had a few minutes. Uh
but uh I just just to talk about some
some big picture stuff.
Um so
these marker messages are messages that
get sent
as part of the the snapshot algorithm
itself.
So the marker messages
don't themselves get included in the
snapshots that we're taking because what
we want to do is take a a picture of the
state of the system and we don't want
the snapshot algorithm itself to
interfere with the snapshot that we're
taking. So the marker messages are just
an artifact of the snapshot algorithm.
Uh you wouldn't want your snapshot
algorithm to interfere with the thing
it's taking a snapshot of. So, these
messages themselves are not included in
snapshots.
Questions. So,
yeah. So, we're going to talk more about
this next time and I'm going to actually
write down all the steps of the
Chandy-Lamport algorithm. Uh we don't
have time to do it today.
Um but um
uh
uh but but there's a question in chat
which is the is the marker message sent
immediately after after the first event
in the snapshot. So, yeah. So, the Well,
I don't know what you mean by the first
event in the snapshot, but the way that
the algorithm works is you take a
snapshot of your own state which
includes all of the events that have
happened on you up until now and then
you send a marker message.
Uh somebody just asked about vector
clocks. Uh so, the question is are the
vector clocks, if used, part of the
snapshot? Um so, vector clocks aren't
actually part of the the Chandy-Lamport
algorithm. Uh
they're I guess they're
um you could kind of you could think of
this as as as being related to vector
clocks in the sense that when we get
done, we're going to have a snapshot uh
that doesn't uh
violate happens before in these ways.
So, after you were done taking the
snapshot, if you were to go and assign a
vector clock to every event, then you
would see that um that you hadn't uh
included anything in the snapshot that
led to inconsistency.
Um but uh
but the but vector clocks don't they're
they're not explicitly part of this
algorithm.
Um in fact, this algorithm predates the
invention of vector clocks.
Another question in chat is uh
are these these uh independent snapshots
or smaller pieces of a larger snapshot?
So yeah, I think I said that a second
ago, but yeah, S1 and S2 here are
snapshots of individual processes and
then the purpose of this algorithm is to
collect individual
snapshots of process snapshots of
processes that can then be later
stitched together into a
um
into a global snapshot that makes sense.
Uh so
next time we're going to go through a
much more detailed or actually we're
going to go through this simple example
again, but we're going to talk about it
in more detail and then we're going to
go through a much more detailed example
of the Chandy-Lamport algorithm. Uh
and uh
I'm also going to share a blog post that
I wrote which is about the
Chandy-Lamport algorithm. Uh so it turns
out that there's this same example that
gets reused over and over uh and
somebody put it in their lecture slides
um and it seems to be copied by everyone
um
but uh
for one thing there's like some mistakes
in it and then it's also
in my opinion just kind of hard to
understand. So I'm going to use that
same uh
uh
example for this for explaining this
algorithm, but I'm going to try to
explain it uh
uh in a
in a way that doesn't make the mistakes
and
uh
is a little bit makes a little bit more
sense.
Uh last question in chat uh
So this is a way to flush messages in
transit. Yeah, okay. So um yeah, so
great point. Yeah, so
when we talked about so this earlier
picture I had
um
not sure where it went. Um
but the earlier picture I had where this
was part of the snapshot here
uh
and then this message from C to D got
included in the snapshot as well uh
because this marker message came in
later.
Um so yeah, so this this here would
actually get included in the snapshot
even though it wouldn't be a causality
violation if it wasn't. Um it does get
included there.
Um so I would say this
So the purpose of this snapshot
algorithm isn't is not really
So when you're running the snapshot
algorithm, messages that are in transit
get included in these snapshots.
Um but I wouldn't describe this
algorithm as a way to flush messages in
transit because the point of this
algorithm is more like looking at events
that have already occurred in a system
and then trying to state take a snapshot
of that system which you could then use
for things like debugging or checking
whether a certain property of the system
is true.
All right, that's it for today. Uh we're
already out of time. So next time we're
going to get into a lot more detail
about the Chandy-Lamport algorithm. See
you then.